what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
since spider-man no way home came out
and there have been talks about a fourth
spider-man movie confirmed by marvel
studios president kevin feige and
executive producer at sony amy pascal
fans have been wondering what exactly is
this next film and other films going to
be about we've had somewhat of an idea
thanks to the post credit scene for
spider-man knowing home that involved a
certain symbiote but perhaps the next
spider-man movie the fourth tom holland
spider-man movie could be a lot bigger
than we actually think and perhaps toby
and andrew could be returning along with
tom hardy and i know what you're
automatically thinking all three
spider-man vs venom no that is not what
we're going to be talking about in this
video but we will be talking about the
symbiote god and a possible connection
to thor love and thunder if even half of
these rumors end up being true this is
going to make for one heck of a
spider-man movie and honestly if they
did this story right it could even top
spider-man no way home and i'll explain
why in this video and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe and hit
that notification bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news so i
actually had this idea for some time now
ever since they announced that gore the
god butcher was going to be the main
villain of thor love and thunder
combining this was something that we saw
in guardians of the galaxy this would
actually line up and make sense for a
perfect plot for spider-man 4. so since
spider-man no way home came out rumors
have been going around that toby and
andrew aren't done as spider-man their
respective spider-mans there's news that
andrew could possibly get the amazing
spider-man 3 there's news that toby
mcguire might show up in doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness there's a
lot of stuff going around and i hope
it's all true i hope they return but i
hope they return for this movie with tom
holland i hope we get another spider-man
team up again and rumors going around
right now say that that's what's going
to happen except they're not just going
to be in the very end of this film
they're going to be with tom holland
spider-man from the very beginning the
reason why is because of that post
credit scene where tom hardy's venom is
in the mcu but then he gets taken back
to his own universe the sony universe of
marvel characters but a little piece of
that symbiote stayed behind this is
where the problem starts and it looks
like this is where andrew garfield
spider-man is going to be getting his
wish where he said i want to fight an
alien rumor has it that the three of
them are not just going to go up against
one symbiote but a whole army of
symbiotes and null the creator of the
symbiotes and the god of darkness now
hear me out for just a second because
i'm going to connect this to thor love
and thunder and guardians of the galaxy
and the comic book readers i bet already
know where i'm going with this so noel
originally was just chilling in the
darkness in a place called the abyss
it's a place that existed between the
destruction of the six cosmos and the
creation of the seventh cosmos then one
day he was awakened by the light of
creation when the celestials began to
create the universe which is now the mcu
we would assume and null the god of
darkness didn't exactly like that no was
pretty pissed off so what he decided to
do was retaliate and he created a sword
of living darkness called the all black
and what did he do he went out and
decapitated one of the celestials he cut
the head clean off one of them and where
have we seen this before we have seen
this in guardians of the galaxy nowhere
nowhere is a city that is literally
built inside of the head of a
decapitated celestial so how did the
celestial get its head decapitated in
the mcu it could have possibly been no
especially if you consider the events
that are about to take place in thor
love and thunder stick with me here null
was cast back into the void of darkness
but the head of the celestial was still
with him so he used the head to infuse
cosmic energy from the celestial's head
inside of the sword making it even more
powerful now null still very pissed off
and still seeking revenge on the divine
light that had brought down his kingdom
created a symbiote suit of armor he
created this from the eldritch darkness
that he commanded and then he set out on
a genocidal campaign against the other
gods and life itself and from here he
became a terribly feared legendary
figure for billions of years now at some
point in time down the line null engaged
an army of gold armored gods that had
the power of the light and he killed all
of them but won now know pursued this
remaining survivor and managed to stab
him but he was also stabbed by the god
spear in the head and they both fell
down to a desolate planet now one of the
inhabitants of the planet saw the gods
falling to the ground and being impaled
by the spear of the god the all-black
sword left null and went to this
inhabitant of the planet who is
gore who goes on to be known as gore the
godbutcher who is going to be played by
christian bale in thor love and thunder
now gore goes on to be called the god
butcher because he uses the all black
sword to kill gods and since they have
announced that he is playing gore the
godbutcher i'm assuming that he's gone
around and killed some gods presumably
with the all black sword so we already
have two major connections to null the
god of darkness and creator of symbiotes
in the mcu here now noel's story isn't
done he doesn't die there he actually
goes on and he kind of just forgets
about the thief who stole his sword he
decides not to seek revenge now
eventually he realizes that he can
create symbiotes out of darkness and he
uses them to attach to lesser life forms
rather than eradicating them and he
creates these huge dragon symbiotes but
his reign comes to an end when he goes
to earth and he fights thor thor defeats
them by blasting them with divine light
and the symbiotes kind of shatter and
fall apart and they end up attaching to
good people and from here on out the
symbiotes actually kind of become good
and they actually attack null and they
lock them away in the heart of their
planet which is called klyntar and from
there on out they actually seek to be
good and protect the cosmos and form a
team called agents of the cosmos now i'm
thinking something like this could
happen except instead of thor fighting
these two dragons it could actually be
r3 spider-man fighting null and an army
of symbiotes now among these symbiotes
could be venom and could be carnage
somehow not the carnage that we just saw
in venom let there be carnage but an mcu
carnage and clearly the symbiote that is
left over from tom hardy's eddie brock
and venom being in the mcu is going to
be different as well so the venom and
carnage that they would fight wouldn't
be the ones we've already seen but in
spider-man no way home toby maguire
spider-man said that he fought an alien
it was black and it was gooey and sticky
and it looks like tom holland spider-man
is about to run into the same thing in
which he will probably seek the help of
tobey maguire now of course i
acknowledge that nobody remembers him
including doctor strange but we have no
idea what is about to happen in doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
anything could be possible the spell
could be erased and thanks could be made
right i'm assuming eventually everybody
will know who peter parker is again at
some point in which peter could ask
doctor strange for the help of toby
maguire's peter since that spider-man
has fought this symbiote before since
that's what he's mentioned and why not
bring in good ol andrew since he always
wanted to fight an alien and they could
use the help from here i do think that
from a story point this would be a
really awesome story seeing the three
spider-man work together to fight
against a symbiote army that's a very
spider-man type of feel this could start
the actual real venom in the mcu by the
new venom symbiote bonding to peter
parker at first only for peter to reject
it and that could eventually lead to a
carnage storyline down the road as well
and i do kind of hope that if this all
happens they actually bring tom hardy's
eddie brock and venom in the mcu to help
them after all he was already in it
before for like
we'll say it five hours or something
like that why not bring him back but let
me know what you think about this in the
comments down below is this a story that
you would like to see for spider-man 4
or would you like to see it go in a
different direction let me know and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you